Congress is looking at remedies for the
high cost of prescription drugs Health
and Human Services Secretary Alex Azar's
testifying to a Senate committee this
morning about a White House plan to
lower prices nearly two years after
taking heat for the rising cost of
EpiPens pharmaceutical giant Milan is
making strides in the fast-growing
biosimilar market biosimilars our drugs
and devices made to be similar to
already approved products potentially
lowering the cost of treatment Milan one
FDA approval last week for a biosimilar
drug designed to help some cancer
patients reduce infection infection risk
during chemotherapy heather brush is the
CEO of Milan she joins us only on CBS
this morning good morning good morning
lots to talk to you about a lot of
people on cancer drugs say there are
tens and tens of thousands of drugs what
would this new FDA approval do with the
biosimilar that your company is
producing look it's an important
milestone for patients and our health
care system as you just said these are
drugs that cost tens of thousands of
dollars costing billions to our system
so as we're able to bring the first
biosimilar product to Neulasta this
important product it's just it's a
marker to what we have to continue to do
our commitment to access to bring
actually we have one of the largest pipe
lines of biosimilars in the industry is
that new these biosimilars yeah I was
thinking that what are they exactly I
want so biosimilars if we quickly think
about a drug a drug is made with
chemicals a biologic is comes from a
living cell a protein a tissue so you
can imagine in complexity the molecular
structure of a biologic is just that way
more complicated than that of say
aspirin or a tablet or capsule so as we
think about these biologics or typical
injectable drugs and they're obviously
very difficult to replicate so they
biologics have been around for quite a
while
the FDA has continued to work with
industry to how can we have the rigor
around making sure we can bring
affordable alternative options to
biologics and those are biosimilars and
dr. Gottlieb has spoken quite a bit
about how much they're needed in our
system and how much that they're going
to reduce the burden of the healthcare
system overall so help us understand the
reduction in that burden people usually
when you talk about the reduction of
they talk about generics so what's the
difference first of all and then second
of all how much of a cost reduction are
we talking about here big savings give
us can you give us some kind of
percentage or so as someone who's been
making generics for almost 60 years
Milan has over 7,000 products over 600
here in the United States so we're one
of the leading providers of generic
medicines when we talk about biosimilars
they're just that they're similar to the
biologic because you're talking about
living organisms and replicating and
showing that they work they're
clinically equivalent they're given the
word biosimilar versus saying a generic
to the biologic so that's really the
main difference but from a science
perspective you know FDA has put a lot
of rigor around making sure that they're
going to work the same for patients and
then I'm savings that can be saving
significant savings as we said tens of
thousands of dollars we'll be launching
our biosimilar two new lasts in the
coming weeks at a significant reduction
you know double digits reductions
further you and I have talked over over
the years about a number of things and
specifically because a beep and Milan
makes the EpiPen yes what did you learn
from that experience in the controversy
surrounding that price hike well the
first important thing I learned that
when you're in the middle of a crisis no
one wants to hear the rationale or a
justification for it so we took
immediate steps to put a half-priced
product into the market and make sure we
were reaching those patients at the
pharmacy counter because that's that's
not who healthcare is working for today
since then I would say over these last
couple years my commitment was to
continue to talk about the system and
that EpiPen was actually a window in to
the broken system and not working for
patients today and I think that
conversation has evolved tremendously
especially given the president's
blueprint that came out over the last
couple of weeks yeah you took the heat
and you're still standing but you want
people to know you're much bigger
there's more to this company than EpiPen
much more I mean listen we've been
committed to access for almost 60 years
and fighting actually been the underdog
bringing these important affordable
alternatives to patients we have the
largest cancer portfolio diabetes
cardiovascular so we have a vast array
of products and our commitment not only
from bringing acts has been investing I
mean these products take
clears problem the cost of drugs that's
too high too hot the cot is the
president taking action is it I know in
January the president said you were
gonna Americans would see a substantial
reduction in the cost of drugs hey is
that possible substantial and second of
all what is it like to have the
president put his finger on your
industry because some people have seen
particularly anybody who does
outsourcing a lot of public pressure
comes on them that they don't exactly
want so talk about that and is there an
opportunity here at the president's
leadership for substantial reduction in
drug costs look I applaud the president
I said when we spoke 18 months ago if
there's one thing you can say about this
president he's solution solution
oriented and not afraid to be disruptive
you can't take a system that's been
built over 50 years and think that you
can just superficially or through a
sound byte change it when you think
about as a country we spend three point
three trillion on health care which is
almost more than double than any other
country and we have one of the worst
outcomes for people so the system the
entire system is broken when we're
talking just about pharmaceuticals I
think that as the president has talked
about a blueprint for how do we make it
market-based and how do we bring
transparency and I think that that would
bring tremendous savings to patients but
that sounds a lot more slow than what
he's promising very substantial fast
reduction in cause so is his promise
unrealistic no I would say that many of
the things outlined in his blueprint are
administrative actions so these aren't
things that would take a long period of
time I mean there are things that
certainly secretary a czar through HHS
and administrative powers that they
could absolutely bring transparency I
mean when you think about shopping
over-the-counter medicine you have
choices brand generics you know what
they cost we have zero ability to know
when you walk up to that pharmacy
counter what a product is going to cost
any product and the reality is every
time you go to fill that prescription it
could cost something different depending
where you are and your deductible this
is your point because myelin is the
second largest provider of prescription
drugs in the country your point is that
there's a lot of middlemen or middle
women taking a cut at different points
in the drug price that go into that big
drug price
that's right there's a huge disconnect
and if you think few years ago you could
have paid a copay five ten twenty
dollars that had no relation to what the
value of what you were getting so we did
a disservice for patients and today we
need some rules of the road we need we
need people patients to be engaged in
their health care and they need to be
able to use data and technology to make
sure they're making the best option for
their for their illness all right had a
branch thanks so much for being with us
yeah